okay only fans
management I had to tackle this one man
somebody asked well description help
girls start promote scale
successfully selling pictures of their
butthole online all right so let's take
a look this as a business model now the
the these management firms are
um out there they're sold a lot to guys
a lot of a lot of people think oh you
can make a lot of money there's loads of
let's go through this let's go through
need four employees you're going to need
chicks you're going to need chicks that
are taking pictures of their butthole so
and you know women are not the best to
work with and they're finicky and
demanding and they've got all kinds of
unreal
expectations
uh I like I cringe at the idea of of of
running a business like this not
interest I mean objectively I'll score
to three if I use the rich score I'd
probably give it a one or a two it's not
something that I'm I don't like it
recur like you're catering to simps
right like you're like you're
manipulating simps and extracting money
from them simps or simps I mean you know
you've heard the argument before well if
I don't do it somebody else is g to do
it well you don't have to do it there's
other you can do which is a little
more you know upstanding that you can be
proud recurring Revenue yep these
will definitely give you their
credit card and pay monthly
afford a whole sellable not really I
mean let me think about this is it
sellable let's say you have a book of
business and you
got a dozen two dozen three dozen
thoughts that you're splitting Revenue
with 5050 7030 you know whatever it
happens to be as long as you build a
good business and you have them uh on
your book of business is it sellable is
a system sellable could somebody come
along potentially buy it yes is is a
demand High there for it not super high
I mean I'm G to give it a seven 7.5
let's give it a
7.5 can it grow to a million dollars a
year um there's a lot of people out
there that'll tell you that these are
very profitable again I know a lot of
not a lot I know a handful of guys I can
count them on one and a half hands that
have run or tried to run only fans
management
company and they've all gone out of it
they've all gotten out of it mostly
because you're dealing with finicky
loser women that are selling pictures of
their butthole I mean you're not dealing
with players you're not dealing with uh
a type of employees okay so can it grow
to a million
bucks
potentially difficult I'm gonna give it
a
six high demand yeah there's a lot of
simps up there we gotta give it a
10 uh location independent you could Ju
yeah you could run this from anywhere in
the world government regulations not
right now but I wouldn't be surprised if
they came in the future so I'm give it a
12 uh can it be boot actually no because
it's simps giving money to uh
women let's pop it up to
13 the government doesn't regulate SS
giving money to thought yet can it be
bootstrapped I don't think anyway can it
be bootstrapped yeah this is definitely
bootstrap type of business what was the
score for that out of
15 painkiller or
vitamin painkiller simps you know for
simps it's definitely a
painkiller you know attention of women
ease of marketing it's not that
difficult there's some work that's
involved I'm gonna give it a nine ease
of marketing is just basically giving
away free content on on social media
platforms like Instagram and Twitter and
stuff like that and you know build a
free audience and you Market your free
audience for you know your special
pictures of your butthole or whatever
Freedom
um you know what out of
10 you're gonna be do a lot of managing
you're dealing with women that are again
they're not a players these are women
selling pictures their butthole you've
seen only fans checks are um give this a
five I don't think it's gonna offer a
ton of Freedom you're always gonna have
to monitor them infos service product it
is a it's not a physical product it's
infos service so we're going to go with
yeah I'm GNA give it a high score give
it a eight anyway what does this give us
here please don't be better than cyber
security thank God 106 so it's worse
than video game strategy guide so far
it's the lowest scoring one I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out